i propose to my cousin
this is a joke no
i'm sorry with so many varieties
in our skin tones hair colors and
features
the human race is a marvel of evolution
but what if we all decided
to preserve our family traits
what if everyone started inbreeding
tomorrow would more children die
would kids be more at risk for disease
[Music]
and uh who exactly would we mate with
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if everyone started inbreeding
tomorrow while
inbreeding might be a topic reserved for
today's daytime talk shows it was once
a common practice among royalty
in 1661 prince charles
ii of spain was born to parents who were
uncle and niece unable to speak
until he was four or walk until he was
eight he was the product of centuries
of inbreeding genetically speaking
his family history made charles ii
more inbred than a child born to
a brother and sister so
if we all started inbreeding
would humans go extinct
first let's clear up any confusion
inbreeding is when two close relatives
have a child together inbreeding is how
early humans survived when there were
not many people on the planet
but 75 000 years ago
humanity almost faced a similar fate
the toba volcano erupted in indonesia 75
000 years ago
exploding with the force of one billion
tons of dynamite
the debris and clouds blocked out the
sky for
almost six years plunging the earth
into an ice age it nearly wiped humanity
off the face of the earth according to
geneticist
dr barry starr there were no more than 1
000 breeding pairs of humans left
and with so few people humans were
forced
to repopulate with well whoever was left
alive
and often that meant your own family
this explains why humans share 99.9
of our dna so to an extent
we're all a little inbred but
that 0.1 difference in our dna
is hugely important and
if we were to decide to keep our family
traits
in only our families we might do some
severe
damage to our genomes let's take a
closer look
see we all have 23 pairs of
organized dna called chromosomes in each
cell's nucleus
and every pair of chromosomes has a copy
of each parent's genes some animals
are inbred for their desirable traits
inbreeding may have given your dog its
lovable floppy ears
but in humans the results may not be so
cute or desirable if you breed with
someone who has the same
faulty genes that you have it could
produce a child who
inherits a lot of medical problems in
fact
first cousins have an eight percent
chance
of having a child with a problem after
birth your kids
might develop cystic fibrosis a blood
disease or
even heart problems but the real damage
would come
generations later by then with
less diversity in your gene pool it
might be
harder for your body to survive changes
in the environment
researchers at the eindhoven university
of technology found that
inbreeding may have caused the
neanderthals to go extinct
simulations show that this early version
of humans
lived in small groups their bad genes
caused their birth rates to decrease
until
eventually they died out
and if our descendants can't adapt
easily
their babies could die more often than
ours do
so if you want to decrease the chance of
that happening
you'll need to breathe further down your
family tree
interestingly a study of icelandic
couples found that
those who married a third cousin
produced more children than
previously unrelated couples let's make
it clear
inbreeding itself doesn't create bad
genes
but if you and your partner have the
same bad gene
it's more likely you'll pass it on to
your child
but if both parents do not have the same
genetic mutation
their chance of giving birth to a
healthy baby is
the same as a non-related couples
if we all start inbreeding and parents
become
more aware of the risks to their
children
it might lead to an increased monitoring
of the womb
and parents might choose who their
children mate with
based on the genetic traits of their
family members
generations of children could have their
love lives
mapped out before they're even born
since you'd all be marrying within your
family
you would have a greater need for
genetic counselors
and for medical professionals to deal
with the genetic diseases
being passed to the children if you
become much more
aware of the problems you might give to
your offspring
would you take better care of yourself
none of us can avoid a genetic problem
we're born with
and we don't control who our parents are
but
you might choose to control how much
alcohol you drink or
eat better food or even pop a vitamin
now and then
while some people might think that they
could be preserving a culture or
certain traits through inbreeding it
might have
the opposite effect and like what
happened to the neanderthals if there's
not enough cultural diversity
some genetic traits would just die out
if something causes our population to
drastically decrease
we might have to think twice about
inbreeding
like what if there were only 1 000
people left on earth
well that's a story for another
what if
you